let's talk about Israel taking over the
West Bank they've occupied it for
decades
the difference this time is Israel wants
to make it official the Palestinians
call it in the legal land grab the Arab
League most European countries and the
United Nations are against it too if
implemented annexation would constitute
the most serious violation in
international law so what would
annexation mean for people and the
occupied West Bank what's in it for
Israel and what does the u.s. election
have to do with it
[Music]
when it comes to understanding news out
of Israel and Palestine it helps to look
at a map the fact that the map changes
all the time
well that's part of the problem here's
what it looks like today this part is
considered Israel the Gaza Strip and the
West Bank are under Palestinian control
the real power though lies with Israel
those Palestinian territories are under
an Israeli military occupation and it's
Israel that decides who and what goes in
or out and a whole lot more and this
arrangement is considered illegal under
international law now the map hasn't
always looked like this
this was Palestine before 1948 over time
Israel expanded by winning Wars moving
borders and building settlements the
focus right now is the occupied West
Bank in more than 50 years
Israel's built at least 250 settlements
they're home to more than 600,000
Israeli settlers and all those compounds
are connected by roads that only
Israelis can use it means Palestinians
are trapped on a patchwork of land
blocked by Israeli separation walls and
with limited freedom to travel they have
to get their Israeli military
checkpoints and now Israel wants to
annex some of that territory meaning it
will extend its sovereignty over land it
already occupies now it's unclear which
parts the Israeli government is eyeing
but it could be as much as 30 percent of
the West Bank including the Jordan
Valley maybe more and the Palestinians
see that only one way
it means the theft of land and in the
case of Palestine it's not only the
theft of land but also the displacement
of indigenous Palestinians let's
understand what life is already like for
Palestinians living in the West Bank
Palestinians don't have control of their
own resources they don't have control
over their own economy which means that
Israel basically decides everything
about their lives
[Music]
it's been constantly building and
expanding assessments in the West Bank
expropriating alerting people more than
90% of Palestinians request for
construction are denied by Israel
forcing them to build illegally on their
own land and once they constructed
Israel immediately destroys that it is a
never-ending cycle so what will
annexation change well some Palestinians
say not a lot but others think life for
them is going to get much harder an
exception does will change everything in
the day to day reality proceed
they fear more evictions more
Palestinians displaced even fewer right
so what will be the status of
Palestinians Israel is not likely to
recognize them as resident the
annexation if it happens means that
Israel has declared itself as a country
of appetite a much worse appetite than
what they built South Africa one of the
biggest concerns for Palestinians is the
annexation of the Jordan Valley it'll
give the Israeli military a strategic
vantage point full view and control over
the area plus total access to the Jordan
River
it also means surrounding Palestinian
territories in the West Bank and cutting
off their access to water Jordan Valley
is a huge resource it's hugely fertile
it's where a lot of agriculture is it's
where a lot of water is as well
Palestinian farmers in the West Bank say
they barely get enough water as it is
Israeli settlers in the Jordan Valley
receive almost 20 times more water than
they do all of these issues risk
upsetting Israel's neighbors
like Jordan the Jordan has written that
this would severely affect its peace
relations with Israel and its agreements
and it is a path to institutionalized
apartheid of Palestine and that's not a
recipe for peace so what's Israel's
justification well Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu doesn't even call it
annexation he calls it applying
sovereignty over Jewish settlements
it's something he's always wanted to do
he's made it a campaign promise in the
last three elections but it's not just
Netanyahu the Israeli position has
always been that the country faces the
threat of attack and that the land
they're taking is historically theirs
it's the Mulligan at the tornado the dog
there is the muddling so loud not a no
and it's not something that is a
contraband policy in Israel the illegal
settlement building arm in the West Bank
was spearheaded by an Israeli Labour
government as so-called left-wing
government practically speaking
annexation also makes it easier to build
more settlements usually it's Israel's
defense ministry which approves
construction but if Israel treats
occupied West Bank land as its own
settlement construction would boil down
to local paperwork it would be much
easier to these communities and to push
them into the Palestinian includes all
these plans were supposed to go ahead in
July but they're on hold for lots of
reasons the details about annexation
still haven't been worked out and
Netanyahu's coalition partner Benny GATT
says he'd rather focus on fighting the
coronavirus for now at least even the
Americans want more discussion but
there's no question they're on side
in fact annexation is part of the Trump
administration's plan for the region
what the president calls his deal of the
century Jared Kushner his son-in-law and
senior advisor drew up the blueprint he
says offers a two-state solution for
Israelis and Palestinians to live
side-by-side but the Palestinians
weren't consulted and they're not buying
it the plan promises a future
Palestinian state in exchange for Israel
annexing large parts of the West Bank
Palestinians rejected the deal then why
the enola
and let the Israel Puna Helena the
Egyptians for three years please cheese
they still do now
there is also a US presidential election
in the mix that's in November and plenty
of analysts say Prime Minister Netanyahu
is trying to seal the deal in case Trump
is voted out so there's a moment to hear
that the challenge will be to maintain
that momentum in the face of nearly
universal condemnation editability a
record had horses horses Eskenazi ones
put inside even some Israeli settlers
aren't happy with annexation but for
different reasons
because Trump's Middle East plan gives
the Palestinians a state of their own no
matter how small and disjointed Jewish
families would remain surrounded by an
Arab entity it's just what wouldn't work
[Music]
that's why many Palestinians we've
spoken to say the whole idea of reaching
some kind of two-state solution has been
a non-starter for a long time some vast
majority of Palestinians know that the
two-state solution is really that they
just probably don't want to face the
autopsy holding Israel accountable is
not about ability or capability it's
about political will the Netanyahu is
sitting very very comfortably indeed for
the first time ever there are Arab
states creating and signing agreements
with Israel it's a different dynamic
that could give Israel the political
space to forge ahead with annexation
which many Palestinians expect Israel to
do anyway Oh Ezra has done since 1967
and even before is to ensure that
Palestinian state will will never exist
Palestinians say it's about Israel's
track record that's something they know
well they don't see annexation as a
moment or a particular date but as
decades of Israeli policy that have gone
unchallenged and right now they don't
see that changing
to find out more about the annexation
plans I'd recommend visiting
al-jazeera's website and clicking on the
Interactive's tap the AJ labs team has
crunched the numbers and put together
really informative maps that help
illustrate what's going on in the West
Bank I'll see you all next week
[Music]